the really nice thing about it is that
my mum's been to some of the events with
me so we go to amsterdam to this amazing
spa
and so she every time we go she's like
i'm coming i'm
while it's been really nice i my sister
sunbathed in the garden with me in the
nude
um my brother is still quite happily
walking around with just the boxing he
was like
so you're just like naked all the time
then now it's like
yeah i knew it's not all right
[Music]
i feel like i got in really late into
the game i only found out by when i was
26 nearly sat like two three years ago
what are some of the
advantages when you think about how much
people spend on new clothes for holidays
and putting the extra like baggage and
stuff in i'm like
i ain't got any of that to worry about
like i just basically need a towel like
that's the etiquette of british naturism
and naturism in general you sit on a
towel
so i can go on holiday for two weeks
with like a small carry-on bag
you know i think that's great but i
think you find like a different value to
things
so you know like i've now made friends
with people who
if i met them in a clothed environment i
would probably not have
encountered with them at all because we
dress
differently so we might not
mix if that makes sense because that's
kind of like how your brain
works normally that you would go for
people that are
you know similar to what you have or
what you are in your taste
every day
it's not sexualized in the same way as
a lot of the time the media portrays
like nudity and sexuality a lot of the
time they're so closely linked
but actually they're not at all it's
just very much like i think for naturism
it's very much just these are people
these are not like sexual objects these
are just people and they are just there
and like living i don't worry about
someone seeing you but if i was ever to
try and impress somebody i'd want to
wear clothes because they're going to
hold me in the right places they're
going to kind of like flaunt the right
bits
so i'd probably dress up to impress
somebody if i had to
having clothes on that kind of like
shape your body a bit more show off your
curves
you know as a female you know puts the
boobs right where they want to be and
not kind of a little bit hanging down
so i'm even for myself i don't think
that
nudity is all that sexy i actually think
clothes are really
guy wants to get excited what
happens well i mean all right this
sounds like ridiculous but
like our advice is that you just go and
sit down and just take two minutes
right wait for the moments pass and then
continue your day
i imagine it probably would be a little
bit embarrassing but
you know if it was gonna happen all the
time then
you're probably not here for the right
reasons either and and i'll be honest
it'd get boring fast
the really nice thing about it is that
my mum's been to some of the events with
me so we go to amsterdam to this amazing
spot
and so she every time we go she's like
i'm coming i'm
while it's been really nice i my sister
sunbathed in the garden with me in the
nude
um my brother is still quite happily
walking around with just the boxing he
was like
so you're just like naked all the time
then now it's like
yeah on your site all right i mean we're
not really a household that was
kind of like strict to being dressed all
the time
i've never had any negative interactions
realistically
um i mean so the last one that we went
on we bumped into two guys they were
fine they actually just asked us
why we did the walk as naturist and uh
you know we had just really nice
conversation with them and then the next
people that bumped into they were
actually running past anyway
but not because of us they were already
running i am but that was like family
with like like mum and dad and two kids
but it wasn't an issue they just you
know
it was just i mean the guy was like feel
a bit overdressed and that was
as much of a comment as was made people
are really polite it's very much like
dog walkers in the morning where
everyone says hello to each other it's
just kind of the same you walk past hi
you all right oh yeah you and
that's it you know there's also people
who have got like families that are in
naturism so
their kids are coming into naturism
they're they don't have to be nude if
they don't want to be they've got the
complete option of being dressed or not
dressed that's fine
but they're in an environment where they
learn what like normal bodies look like
i've got so many friends who have got
like hang-ups on
what their body image is you know the
size of the clothing being part of their
worth and things like that and i just
find it really stressful like and i
wouldn't want
my children to have to feel like that
and know that like no normal bodies
exist and it's
beautiful to have a normal body like
perfect is non-existent you know the
imperfections that we all have
are kind of like what tells you apart
from other people and also it's kind of
like your story or background
what would the world be like if all of
us were new
maybe people would be kinder because if
we're all wearing our own insecurities
basically on our sleeves then
you know you're probably going to be a
little bit kinder because you might
think to your own self in the morning
like
god i don't feel like great today but
you're then not going to go out and pick
at somebody else i mean my favorite
thing is that if you point your finger
at someone that's three pointing back at
you
and so the faults that you find in other
people are normally insecurities that
you hold on yourself it kind of has
just made me love myself that little bit
more you know like
yeah i might have a bit of back fat
wearing whatever and you know i might
just
have a few rolls when i sit down but i'm
well fed
and i like food so you know why should i
why should that bother me
it's really good for your mental health
to kind of accept
who you are as a person so just try it
just stand in front of the mirror
and look at yourself naked it's not bad
i promise
you